[Music]
the title of Grand Master was first
officially awarded in 1950 now in 2017
at the st. Louis Winter Invitational
that tradition continues hello chess
fans and welcome to the final wrap-up
report after round nine here at the
Winter Invitational the GM and I am norm
tournaments three players tata abraham
ian joel bana wa and justice Williams
have either earned an International
Master norm or have gained the title
itself in the Grand Master norm field we
have one of our local favorites maybe a
second hometown adopted a daughter you
might say woman Grandmaster tattoo of
Abraham Ian who today got two four and a
half points with her victory over a
Nikhil Kumar congratulations you know
take us through the game I kind of I
actually just looked up the line and I
found a couple of games they all ended
in a drop but something it's a little
Pleasant for white because my bishop is
very strong any opponent because of the
pawn structure and the pawn ending is
winning for me because I'm kind of
playing up a pawn because he cannot
create a passed pawn on the Kings side
I think Queen trade should be a winter
because she cannot move the knight so
it's kind of hard for him to really do
much because any kind of trade is bad so
he always has to keep that in mind and I
kind of can start trying to push my
Queen side pawns this bring my King
around so I have improvements and I
think it's harder for him to find
improvements because if he so first of
all he needs to fix his King and then he
needs to figure out what he's gonna do
it it's King side and if he pushes
something like f6 it's gonna weaken his
King and they're still Queens on the
board like here 23 so yeah so for
example if he plays Queen d7 like this
on game should just be lost
so I should bring my king create a
passed pawn and then like this pawns are
completely useless so if he goes at five
I can simply take take and I'm basically
up upon 36 so he's trying to play up six
bring his knight into the game Bishop c3
so son if now have six maybe I can put
my bishop on before and now this King
gets again maybe not so happy
so if King F seven I can't even try
something like a 4 trying to push d5 so
he didn't really find any ideas he just
kind of waited around before so I'm
getting everything I want in like I'm
pushing my Queen said I'm bringing my
king in I can create a pass bond and
he's just waiting so I'm just like I'm
getting free moves in actually I'm not
even sure what he should be doing here
here maybe you should have put the King
on the Queen side and that played 98 so
and then he played Queen d7 I think the
son game is already very bad for him so
he traded Queens I think this end game
is already lost because he still needs
to do something about his King side to
bring his King in and my king is so
close and I can start pushing my pawns 5
at 6:00
he played b5 I think if he goes King g7
just looks winning and I want to push
this because I'm gonna play c6 and have
my a pawn distant past pawn and then my
King is gonna run over to the King side
they played b5 and I think this ending
is always just winning because here's a
lot of problems here first of all I'm
creating the passband and second of all
you cannot even activate his Knight
because after a check and cannot bring
the King over because again this fixed
pawn structure is just devastating so I
think from here on is very
straightforward so I just won the pawn
so I'm completely winning so just made a
few moves pawns are turned coining so
it's something god of desperation
so of course I'm just winning so
opponent game or even if we don't go
into a pond and game b67
just winning the game well
congratulations tattoo thank you
now you were the lowest rated player in
the GM norm field coming in here and so
your performance exceeded what was
expected you might say and also you
technically earned and I am norm in the
GM norm field but it doesn't really
matter in your circumstance do you even
know how many I am norms you have
anymore
I thought I had five but now I'm kind of
double guessing maybe maybe this is my
face so now it's all about getting to
that 2400 mark and I expect we'll see
you back of course for the US Women's
Championship at per tradition so that's
always a great event who you looking
forward to playing in that event coming
up I guess maybe the newer players
because I feel like I've played against
on and crush so many times
good interesting it sure does and that's
coming up on March 28th and going from
March to April and that will be on us
chest champs calm as well Tata thank you
for joining me
it's been an honor as always and let's
take a look at the final standings for
the GM norm field in this field
grandmaster David Burgess one clear
first place however perhaps the story is
Tata of Abraham ian's norm winning
performance finishing clear above what
was expected of her given she was the
lowest rated player in the field coming
into the I am norm section I think we
have the story of the entire tournament
the former fidei master now
International master Joe Elba Gnawa has
gotten his rating over 2400 he has all
of his norms and here he is to show his
eighth round game Joel congratulations
first of all but this is a wage thank
you so round 8 against Michael Brooke
let's see how you clinched it this is an
interesting point where just like what I
mentioned earlier sometimes you have to
evaluate the position before you capture
in exchange because I've had a lot of
experience in the past where I grabbed
the exchange right away and it turns out
that the night is actually or the minor
piece is much more powerful than the
rook and I wasn't sure if if it's in
just like this instance after for
example Bishop takes f6 Bishop takes I
have to be really careful Queen takes d6
I was thinking about it but after Queen
takes h5 and if I just start grabbing
pawns on the Queen side of the sudden he
has to move Bishop h4 and then he could
move to Bishop to g3 and maybe Bishop f4
or he could start activating the rook
even though I'm up by a lot of points
there I don't really have any ideas or
plants in this position but just to wait
and if you're up you really don't want
to give your opponent counter play as
much as possible so this would be an
ideal position for black and that's the
reason why I didn't take the rook right
away I had to evaluate the position
first before capturing in luckily I
found this Ruth Madoff one I really like
I really love this move and the point is
after Queen takes h5 Bishop takes I can
get rid of the piece that holds on to
his whole position his whole position
has a lot of weaknesses but this Bishop
keeps it all together and if I could get
rid of that Bishop and the he captures
back on d5 then my Rick could start
penetrating they have 5.0 4 he has a lot
of problems now black lady should be 7
Knight takes e4 ok and now I have I have
a lot of play in the position Rick aged
7 9 takes d6 Bishop d5 and here at this
point I was
I wasn't really intending to play g4
originally I was thinking about playing
c4 but I thought that maybe it might
give him some chances
it might weaken my opponent before I
didn't really calculate anything
concrete but when I saw g4 I thought
that will simplify everything it's
really odd just it seems like I would be
giving him too much counter play after
chief for but thanks to my rooks
especially my rook in the second rank I
could actually eight my king very easily
and transform my defensive position into
an offensive offensive position and here
I was expecting rich g7 Queen h4 is also
possible Queen h3 well yeah Queen h3 r
h2 and I was okay with this in game this
endgame was fine even though my King
looks a bit exposed without the Queen's
on the board my position is great
there's nothing here
black ass no follow-up and I'm just up
by a lot of material Queen h3 maybe more
interesting oh sorry Queen h4 Bishop
takes f5 is probably what I would have
played and Knight takes and I was I was
again very happy about this position I
didn't think I had any problems and on
my Rick could go to h2 and take one h6
for example Queen here let's say this
happens I could probably take one f3
calculated something like this where
Knight takes h6 I think it was 1986
first anyway that that end game should
be winning for white I have a lot of
points and I could create pass pawns on
the Queen side very easily so he decided
not to do that
we decided that rook g7 will probably
give me the biggest problems but I think
at this point of already calculated the
following sequence after work h2 in
Bishop h4 that
the tactic that he performed in the game
wasn't gonna work I was I think yeah I
think this position is already lost
after Bishop age 4 yeah I was I was
expecting Bishop takes f3 but I think
what my opponent missed was that the
fact that if I just move my king he was
probably relying on this tactical idea
of performing a discovery attack against
my queen unfortunately I will just take
it with check and now he's just in an
absolute pin the rook is pinned down the
bishop is pinned down the Queen can't
really move and his king is not safe 1g8
I have quick ideas and that will win me
some more materials such as Queen takes
g4 followed by Knight takes h6 or knight
takes h4 the position is now completely
lost and I was I was pretty happy about
that game it was a pretty complex game
and now I was just I was just really
happy that allowed me to clean [ __ ]
2,400 rating absolutely and that was
yesterday now today you came up short
but I would imagine that it's tough to
keep your spirits down anyway that's
right it's not every day that this
happens so Joel a very congratulations
very big one to you and thank you for
giving us your time my pleasure and you
know you're also finishing at the the
top of the standings here so let's take
a look for the last time at our final I
am norm field standings to finish up
Joel bonala and justice Williams finish
tied first in this field justice
Williams has earned an IM norm
Joel Manawa on the other hand has gotten
his feet alo rating over 2400 and with
more than three norms to his credit he
is now officially an international
master
I'm here with Pete a master justice
Williams back again and that only means
it's good news justice you have hit the
magic six and a half points after a draw
today with Doug Eckhart yeah there
wasn't really much in this opening in
this game really was just about securing
a draw but yeah throughout the
tournament I took the bell going not
eight and a half out of nine and I
almost did it I almost did it I got six
in half and I only lost one game and
even that game I was better against Joe
was a yeah he's a really good player but
um other than that I thought I played
pretty well good enough for norm and I
just set the bar high you know right
exactly and and Doug likes to it kind of
brings him up when he's not doing too
well in a tournament you know a lot of
times he plays tougher fields he was
telling me the other day that it brings
him up to not not kind of gift people
the norm but when people can norm off
him the you know that's kind of
uplifting you were 20 minutes or so late
for the first round because of
transportation issues is that right yeah
it's like every time I every time I'm
close to getting my um title is just
something bad happens and today uh I
called a cab and it just never showed up
so we had to recall the cab um well and
you only have half an hour today I have
half an hour to make the round and I was
about what 15 minutes late already so it
was pretty well when I first got my when
I got my I am norms the same thing
happened on I played in the tournament
call it up something in North American
and I was 7 for 8 and and clear first by
a full point and all I needed was like a
drawer to secure it and I lose the last
round so I lose the title but I gain a
norm and then next year following that
not the same situation but um I tied for
first again and I get second place off
the tie break so I wouldn't get the
title but I get the norm so it was kind
of like looking it was it was looking it
was looking like something something was
stop me from getting that title but uh
it's a good thing your cab came and that
was fine thank goodness because when you
came up those stairs might come er he
whipped the wipe the sweat yeah it's
like we just avoided a tragedy so that's
very cool congratulations on your
performance we like you so much we'll
forgive you for that jacket right there
the Cubs fan I guess so yeah justice
Williams now he's just fighting for the
rating 3 I am norms he's got it so
congratulations to him a lot of these
names you might be hearing for the very
first time in the future though don't be
surprised if you see a few of these
players show up in the US Championships
that will do it for this 2017 winter
invitational and by the look of these
stories I'd say it was a smashing
success
expect the st. Louis chess club to bring
you more of these norm tournaments in
the future and you can see it right here
on YouTube and us chess champs calm
and one more thing for the past five
years this YouTube channel has brought
you the most compelling lecture videos
and live tournament broadcasts in the
entire chess world with the occasional
silly video on the side as well we want
to thank you the YouTube viewers who
have made this channel truly what it is
today
100,000 subscribers strong so for all of
you who have really heated the advice to
like share and subscribe thank you so
much and we'll have much more for you
coming down the road